[Music]
many of us can remember
when captain sully sullenberger landed a
u.s airways airbus on the hudson river
how would you react if you were on the
plane that day
rick elias who's a super successful
venture capitalist
was on that plane i wanted to talk to
him to understand the lessons he learned
from a near-death experience
and how it transformed him this
is a bit of optimism
i wanted to start january 15 2009
flight 1549 from laguardia to charlotte
this is the plane that landed on the
hudson river
and you were on that plane and one thing
i know
because you've talked about it is how
that experience
changed you can you tell us what
happened that day
and how it affected you yeah listen it
was january 15th so it was very cold in
new york
um i had had a good dinner the night
before for work i got up early
went to play hoops on the upper west
side and i remember walking with snowing
these big flakes and i'm like guys so
beautiful i'm just going to walk to the
gym and
i had a couple meetings went to
laguardia it was coming home i've taken
that flight a hundred times
and i was coming home and have my son's
basketball game when we landed and i
needed a coach
uh and you know that was that was it i
was coming home it was a normal day it
was it was gloomy and rainy and cold
in in new york city but to get to the
crux of it
i was given the ultimate gift simon the
ultimate gift to me
uh was a near-death experience with zero
suffering
when no one died so you can talk about
it freely
where you had a hundred percent
certainty of death
so to me the question was am i going to
blow up or am i going to drown in
freezing waters
and with 90 seconds to really look at
life
and say goodbye so all that combination
to me made it it wasn't too long it
wasn't too short
kind of this the right kind of
parameters to to
really change your perspective in life
and i was giving them a massive gift
which was the chance to come back and
live differently
that's my whole goal in life now i know
that when i die i'm going to ask myself
one question
is did you make the most out of the
second chance you got
what were you like before or
what most profoundly changed after
i was caught up on the race i was caught
up on building a business i was caught
up on
making money i was caught up on i'm
being successful
it was probably like most people in
similar circumstances that i had a
little luck i was starting to believe it
was because of me
i was starting to get a little bit of a
big hit um
you know our business was really booming
but what really changed that day for me
is realizing simon that it all changes
in an instant
you know we can talk about other stuff
right now in this covet environment but
it was the realization that
we can't postpone the things that matter
to us
and that is a hug a forgiveness an
experience
you know we talked a little bit about
this but my only original thought is
you know i collect bad wines i drink my
good ones
and the point of that is that's how i
approach everything in life
i want the things that matter to me i'm
going to prioritize and i'm going to
i'm going to experience them and enjoy
them now and that that was very
clarifying
the reason i like hearing the story and
i the reason i think it's important to
share this story
is because most people won't have
this kind of near-death experience
themselves
and if they do as you said 100 of the
people survived there was no pain
it was the best kind of near-death
experience you can have
but the reason i i think it's important
to share these i think it reminds the
rest of us
i had an experience when i went with the
air force to afghanistan
where i was only supposed to be there
for 24 hours
and the plane that we were supposed to
come home on
we couldn't get on it because they
needed the space for
um wounded warriors to bring them home
which is a good reason to get bumped off
an aircraft
it's the best one ever we couldn't get
on another plane and we were going to be
stuck there for at least four days
and i didn't tell my family that i was
gonna
be in afghanistan and now they won't
hear from me
wow plus when we landed ten minutes
after we landed
the base came on a rocket attack i've
never been in a war zone before and i've
three rockets hit a hundred yards off
our nose and so this intense paranoia
came over me
that i was gonna die in afghanistan
because i just didn't know that's how my
parents would find out i was there
and i remember the intensity of those
feelings and the panic and the
you know becoming someone i'm not and
sort of the way i talk to people wasn't
me
you know like you get me on that plane
is the way i talk i'm like i don't talk
to people that way
but i have one intense memory i remember
being self-aware enough
to say to myself you better remember
these feelings yeah
you better remember this and have you
been successful
i have and one of the ways i've been
successful is i've told the story many
times and i tell it more for myself than
i do for others
and i'm able to go back to that time and
find those feelings again because i made
a specific i put a bookmark
long story short we did get on another
plane home that day
and it was an unscheduled flight where
we brought home a fallen soldier
where i flew for nine and a half hours
in the back of a cargo plane with a
flag draped casket and it changed me
wow i think one of the things that you
and i have both done
is we've taken these experiences and yes
we've internalized them and yes we've
we've been able to live differently
because of these experiences
one of the things i love talking to you
about is you're very
happy to share everything you know
you're not possessive
with the lessons you've learned and this
is a dog eat dog world
you know every little lesson every piece
of information you have it's considered
advantage
one of the things i find inspiring about
you is you're so
generous with what you've learned first
of all is
thank you and and second of all i i kind
of joke i'm like the forrest gump of
ceos
you know so i i never thought i would be
in this position
and it is with a lot of humility that i
accept the responsibility of
you know leading 4 000 people across the
globe and
if people knew how little i knew most of
the time they would
never the right team right so
i uh you know i was a kid that grew up
in puerto rico and
i was a normal kid and there was nothing
about me that said i was gonna be able
to
get to this situation and i look back
and we all work hard i just the ball
bounced my ways more often than not and
you know the day that that changes uh
is that i'm a different person do you
think that luck
is made i mean you talk about being
lucky a lot
do you actually believe that yeah 100
100 now you can improve your odds for
sure
and you can learn from a lot of the
things that people will deem unlucky
that ultimately may result in bigger
luck and you believe that i know that
but i do believe that you know it a lot
of times it's
understanding that you're getting lucky
listen we were born in incredible
situations in an incredible time period
in great families and
that's all luck having our health is
perhaps the most remarkable luck you can
have right
you know find me anybody that is worth
billions of dollars that is
dying or sick and they'll trade at all
you know i i think luck can be very
basic but also can be
opportunistic you know i struggle with
the concept of luck and i consider
myself lucky
and i semi joke that my biggest fear is
that my luck will run out
yeah and i look at my own career and
people like you did this you did this
and i was like
no i was lucky there was lucky there and
the timing was really in my favor there
you know it's like my ted talk when it
went viral in 2009
i mean it happened at a time where there
weren't that many tedx talks yeah
and so i there's no way it would stand
out now it just just wouldn't happen
there's just too much
i got lucky there's no other way to
describe it but very recently
i've started becoming uncomfortable with
the term
lucky and it came from listening to
people
when i would watch interviews on
television or something with people who
were born
especially people who were born into
extreme wealth and they had this
humility
where they wanted to sort of downplay
their position because they knew they
didn't earn it
and they would say to the interviewer
you know i'm very very lucky
and i realized it was almost demeaning
to call it lucky like the rest of us are
unlucky
yeah and i realized the things that i
would say that it's like i was lucky
because i'm trying to sort of
be humble about that i don't deserve
this but i realized
it doesn't sound nice and so i realized
it was an insecurity
and so what i started doing is calling
it gratitude
instead of saying i'm lucky that this
happened i'm saying i'm grateful i'm so
grateful that i was able to give that
first ted talk
at a time where there weren't that many
ted talks yeah
the differences and i can see how you
would want to put it in that way
is did it happen to you or did it happen
because of you
and in in many ways you know someone
that was born into a lot of wealth and
by the way i
i think that most of those people are
actually unlucky
because they're robbed from a lot of
things in life and i worry about this
a lot for my kids i worry that
the success i've had has created
a burden on them that is unfair you know
this is why you see
so many kids of what others will
perceive as successful people
really not struggling finding their
rhythm is because they don't have that
ability to achieve more than the parents
achieve or to do certain things that
others do
so you know it's a choice of words i
think gratitude is what you
feel what you feel about something i
think
acknowledgement that you're not in
complete control and then there's
randomness to something that's what i
call luck
you can improve your ought of that
through hard work through
you know commitment through not giving
up and all those things but
it makes me feel better that you know
again this is a belief and the great
thing about beliefs is like you choose
what you want to believe
if it empowers you then choose it if it
holds you back then get rid of it
was the culture in your company
different before 2009 than it is today
i listen to your ted talk and and you
have a lot more lessons than mine
but i loved it i was a
big student of yours even before we
became good friends
but you know i came back and i said hey
i've realized now that this is the perch
where i want to live the rest of my life
and i have no desire to go public and
growth is an important part of
attracting the talent that we want but
this is kind of a race to nowhere which
is the infinite game
right and in the core of the infinite
game is winning in the game is to play
the next game
right so i came back and i decided you
know what i'm the painter of
hopefully a 50-year mural of which i'll
paint the first half someone else
will paint the other ones if we're lucky
enough and who knows how long that paint
will last so
that mindset really changed i was
building a company that i was gonna sell
and then i was gonna go be happy what i
realized is i was sitting on a perch
from which i could do a lot of the
things that matter to me
you know and at the end of the day this
doesn't belong to me it belongs to
itself
i had the opportunity to meet dr karst
before he died he was the originator of
finite
infinite games back in the mid 80s and
of course as soon as i sat down with him
i said
how did you come up with it i have to
ask and he's he was part of this uh
this core of intelligentsia in the mid
1970s who were all talking about
game theory but always with an eye to
win they were always talking about
winning yeah
and dr carr said well what about play
what about the actual game rather than
the end of the game and what i ended up
calling the infinite mindset
he called play and i think a lot of
people especially in business
they keep thinking about the end where
there is none
they keep thinking about the winning
which is impossible but they actually
forget about the joy
of play the joy of work the joy of
building a business or being a part of a
business and you embody this
more than any other ceo i've ever met
just
an absolute love of the game with
no desire to win yeah when i see
successful business people that are
driven their competitive spirit has come
from a fear of failure
they kind of run out of gas yeah you
know if they achieve a lot
they're like wow you know i i don't want
to lose this so i want to cash out
and i see a lot of people that just tap
out of the game because they're just
the burn of losing becomes so massive
because they're winning
if you take the the infinite mindset
back into competitive spirit is this
notion that you're competing only
against yourself
right and when you compete against your
version of yesterday that gives you this
like
endless potential you're never going to
be the best but you can be like
one-tenth of a percent better
tomorrow i think it's very hard for us
right there's always someone prettier
there's always somebody smarter there's
always somebody stronger there's always
somebody luckier always no matter who
you are there's always somebody else
what did teddy roosevelt say you know
comparison is the thief of joy
that's right but it's so hard not to
compare in a world
where so much of what we do is finite
and we do have to
be ahead and we do have to compete for a
job you have to compete for this
nobody at school tells us come to school
just to get a good education you come to
school to get good grades
yeah we define good education by the
grades that we get
not by how much we learned you mentioned
earlier
the the sharing of knowledge you know
there's many ways to to frame people but
some people come from a position of
scarcity and some people come
from a position of abundance you know
when you meet somebody
you can quickly tell where they're
coming from you know if your success
if your thing is something you're taking
away from them perceived or not
those are people that kind of subtract
from you by nature of what you do
you're trying you know as a thinker as a
philosopher
as somebody that is really trying to you
know bring knowledge
uh to you know the masses what you're
really doing is you know
using abundance as a principle and i
think there's something to that
in the in the in the infinite game is
you know you want to associate yourself
with people that are ambitious for
something greater than themselves
and that's really a big principle of of
our company over adventures is like
you know how do you find that and it's
it's again it's the it's an infinite
game in a different
context that's a perfect segue how do
you find that and how you
how do you do that i mean you you know a
lot about a lot of companies
and when you look at the culture of your
company you compare it to others or
quote unquote the norm
yeah what is it that you have been able
to do inside your own company
that is so different than everywhere
else you know my good friend andy meyer
says that a culture is uh
is like a shark if it stops swimming it
dies
and you know a lot of people come and
ask the question so how do you preserve
the culture and the answer is you don't
right your goal is for the culture to
continue to evolve in a way that is
aligned
with where you kind of want the general
energy and direction of the team towards
this
version of infinite game there's no
winning of this you just want to keep
momentum
in progress because life has plenty of
inertia
that you have to overcome it's all
physics you know people will be like
okay so what's your
mission statement what's your vision
what are your values and
your motto was evolving a lot so i was
afraid to kind of anchor on something
but the one that i really struggle with
is this notion of like here are my
values and
you know and i was like but values are
things that i learned at home or i
learned
before i got here i'm not really sure
that i can teach somebody values
and we landed on this word that is
semantics but it matters is
we run our company through a set of
belief systems there's a series of
beliefs that is how we hire
how do we promote how do we encourage
people to go work someone else
and we go to people and say you have to
believe this
and it's a choice but if you don't
believe it you're not going to do well
here
so we have found a common language by
which we get people to almost
opt-in into the journey it's not for
everybody
can you tell me some of the specific
beliefs yeah so
one of my favorite ones is we believe
everything is written in pencil
so what that means is you have to be
really comfortable
with change and adaptability and that
even things that we believe to be true
today
are likely not going to be true in a
couple years so you have to have a
curiosity
in a level of being okay with that so
then what we do is we do lots of things
that will make you
get comfortable with that we'll change
your desk every nine to 12 months we'll
move teams around we don't have a lot of
big groups doing things everybody's
volunteering to other things so
everybody's flexing different muscles
so it's not just what you say is how do
you kind of
you know structure your organization to
do certain things we believe in running
up the escalators
to us pace of play really matters this
is like if you can play business like
you play the two-minute
drill in football you get a lot more
done you drop a lot more passes you do a
lot of things right
i'm not sure we got it right but it's
been a really interesting journey that
it just gave us a common language on
culture building yeah
we want to be great people to work with
so no [ __ ] allowed
yeah if someone has too big of an ego
and that means
you know you walking into our building
people will say good morning
be you get in an elevator people will
smile every new hire i meet with all our
new hires after like 60 90 days i just
like to see their experience
and they're like i'm shocked at two
things i'm shocked at how much you trust
me
and number two i'm shocked at how nice
everybody is unwilling to help me do my
job
right now it it just we are full of
imperfections but
i think when you have a culture that is
in harmony
it doesn't matter what tune your
orchestra is playing as long as every
instrument is
kind of on the same note yeah you have
this
magical mindset you have this amazing
disposition this calm that i wish i had
do you have something that is a constant
nagging struggle to you
it's your boulder you know your sisyphus
boulder the one thing you feel like
you're always pushing
you know i was born and raised catholic
and i even went through confirmation and
i don't practice
organized religion i believe myself to
feel the spirituality i'm not claiming
i'm spiritual
but with that i i let go of guilt like i
have no guilt
it's like you know guilt is a complex i
don't suffer from
so i think if you if you really think
about that bolder question inherit in it
there is some level of guilt that you
carry
that is making that boulder seem like a
boulder
listen i laugh at myself all the time i
really
just realized that i just i'm so ill
prepared for
the role that i have and i'm okay with
it i
i don't i don't beat myself up i'm my
best friend the conversations in my head
are so
positive you know 98 of our
conversations are in our head
why not make him great like and i'm like
wow you were really bad there dude or
like oh wow wow you got lucky look what
happened like
i'm this is what it's in my head all the
time i've been thinking a lot about
friday night i'm going to see my parents
right and until last
a week ago i i will go and kiss my mom
and and
what what uh alzheimer's dimension pain
patient has
is stability still give you a kiss it's
amazing that they they don't remember
anything but they can give you a kiss
and i go and i see my mom and i get a
kiss and and
it makes me yearn for one more
conversation with her and then i sit
outside with my dad and we share
a great bottle of wine and you know i'm
super grateful in this like
knowing that you know i'm in awe that i
can have this
experience with my dad but i'm also
grateful that
i was able to have that with my mom in
life everything we do for the first time
has
all and then everything that we do for
the last time
you know has gratefulness if we could
marry a state of mind
which would be impossible to do where
you can combine both emotions and most
things
like if you and i were together and we
knew this was the last conversation we
were going to ever have
one of us is not going to be here
tomorrow we probably will say a few
things we haven't said correct
for sure it's gonna happen with lots of
people
so is the appreciation i i love that
we're friends i've learned a ton
from you i am grateful that you invited
me to have this conversation
yet in in in some way we we have the
inability
to be there in that sense of both oil
and gratitude
for too long let me play devil's
advocate a little bit here
sure because i'm tempted to have that
conversation with you right now
and tell you how i feel as if this were
the last time
and if it's not the last time do i have
that conversation again
and then if i do it too much if i do it
every time for fear that this is the
last time
does it cease to be special because it
happens every time
it's like somebody who says i love you
too quickly and it's like
when they say it to me i'm like
[Applause]
but you you don't know me but you loved
every boyfriend you had prior
what makes me so specific infinite game
they can love a lot of people why are
you uh trying to connect no
i don't think i don't think you can fall
in love with every person you date
i just don't maybe i'm a cynical bastard
i just
that's not what i said i said i don't
believe you can fall in love with every
person you date
you can absolutely have an infinite
amount of love i think you need some
therapy to go digging that one just talk
to every ex-girlfriend they will agree
with you
oh that is too funny you know but i i
don't think it's
it's a matter of saying it every time
it's making sure that you said it
yeah so what i what i realized you know
in that moment of clarity in those 90
seconds we talked about earlier is that
there were a lot of things i wanted to
say
that i thought i had time to say there
were people i needed to ask forgiveness
from that i never did
there were people that i wanted to tell
them how important they were to me
or how much they had helped me and why
not i think we go through life
not we think we're going to be here
forever those 90 seconds on that u.s
airways plane i didn't realize it was
only 90 seconds
yeah from the moment sully came on and
said this is
and you i assume you heard the engines
go quiet brace for impact
brace for impact and then 90 seconds
later you're on the hudson river yeah
they've done a study on people who face
near-death experiences and they did some
with people who were
parachuting out of a plane and their
parachutes didn't open their first or
second
so they thought they were going to die
and through some miracle they landed in
a swamp and survived
right and they all have the proverbial
life flashing before their eyes
did that happen yes it you know because
you know you can see this the water
coming and as a matter of fact
you almost i had an internal kind of
countdown
when we were gonna hit the water i
closed my eyes
i was holding my own arm and i said i
love you
you know i i tell you something for me
you know having been raised catholic
i always wonder in the moment of death
if i had a moment
that i knew i was going to die was i
going to ask for forgiveness like was it
was i going to buy insurance
i have some friends of mine who's like
you know what i believe in this because
it's insurance and i wonder like it
would have been free it's like a free
insurance that you say
and one of the things i'm most proud of
was the fact that i said you know what
i am who i am and if that's what it took
and not you know my own inhumanity i'm
not going to do it
and that also gave me clarity on coming
back on my relationship with religion
i got to tell you that really that
really chokes me up
that in in this moment of imminent death
after you've thought you know whole life
has flashed before your eyes you thought
about your family that you hold yourself
and say i love you is really profound
and i think it's the thing
that we don't do you know i think that
the term of loving yourself has
unfortunately lost its it's become
pejorative it's become synonymous with
having a big ego
but if you can love someone else and
that's not egotistical like why can't
you love
who you're trying to be or or who you
were when it's the end
you know why why shouldn't we all live a
life that on our deathbeds or
you know being told to get into the
brace position that we hold ourselves
and say i love you
you've lived a good life you've earned
my love
what a standard to live by to earn one's
own love
and the amazing thing about it is you
can't learn that from a book or a
magazine
you learned it in the moment there was
no prediction how you would have reacted
in that situation
some people may have been screaming i
don't know
some people may have found solace and
quiet some people may have been making
phone calls
you know what simon at the core of love
is forgiveness
yeah right and i think we we have such
a difficult time forgiving our own
selves
about our past about our habits about
our own movie in our heads of the things
that we have
failed to do and i think learning to
love ourselves is learning to forgive
ourselves
yeah and to truly forgive and to
[Music]
move forward in a way that you know it's
it's without
carrying the weight of the world too
many people walk around
carrying so much guilt and shame
and society puts it on us and you know
raising teenagers is really interesting
you know it's how do you raise kids that
are accountable but don't feel shame we
have two teenagers and my wife and i are
like
really driven to make sure that we don't
ever shame them
and nor should we shame anyone
well i love you too yeah i love you too
you know it's uh we collect friends and
we collect memories
and hopefully we collect bad wines those
are the three things worth collecting
because if you live that way life is
rich
another friend of mine had this concept
that everything in life should be at
least a three-fer
you ever heard this concept no no i
really like it because
if the ultimate currency in life is time
yeah right
and there's every study that show you
that over 60 000
or something it has zero effect on your
happiness you know the only currency
that really matters at the end of the
day is time
if that's the case how do you get a lot
more yield out of
time and the example he used when he
told me this and i have used it for
everything
is to say hey you love golf you go play
golf that's that's valuable you go play
golf
with your best friends that's two times
valuable you go play golf with your two
best friends in a beautiful day that's
three times value if you do it an
amazing course that's four times
so he always says everything in life
should be a three-four
you know when you talk about things it's
like when you and i
are together i am learning
i am seeing a friend and we're usually
drinking
a good glass of wine or a good coffee
somewhere right so every experience you
should dimensionalize
and that means abundance that means you
bring people together one of the things
that gives me the most pleasure
is when two of my good friends become
great friends so
you know everything in life should be
thought of as maximize the yield out of
your time
i love that i love the idea of making
something a three-fer
once again every time i talk to you
i'm richer and wiser and immensely
immensely grateful
coming from the teacher i'm humbled by
those words i hope our path crossed
before long my friend
please
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and if you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other